how do you help writers find the
emotional spine of their story yeah oh
that's a great question so the emotional
spine is the most important thing
it is the most important thing and
oftentimes it's
one of the last things that becomes
really clear because sometimes you have
to write through a bunch of stuff to
actually realize what the emotional
spine is of your story
but one way that i work with writers on
finding their the emotional spine of
their story is
by using the hero's journey and the
reason i actually like that story model
is i think it's the deepest kind of
psychological model and it really is
about fear
and facing
whatever darkness we have in ourselves
um you know in pursuing what we want
and so
what i do
with writers when they're you know
sometimes writers have a really great
story but i'm like what do they want
what's the emotional growth like what's
their flaw what's their problem
we actually do kind of um talk through
this idea of the hero's journey
and often what's missing is um
like a fear like some people write main
characters that are like perfect like
they're just good people and they always
do the right thing and it's like after a
while it's kind of like wow the
secondary characters are really fun and
interesting and your main character is
just kind of like dull
you know and so how do you um take some
of that juice that you've given your
secondary characters and really create a
main character who's complicated and
flawed you know and it's so good to have
a character that has a flaw because
then they make mistakes which creates
more conflict and then they do things
out of fear which allows us to
understand them more deeply you know and
create structure so which creates
structure for us so so what i do is we
sort of talk through okay
what is your character afraid of
like what is their emotional need let's
say it's love and connection and let's
just say they're afraid of being
rejected just to pick them a really
simple example
right and so
i encourage writers to think about why
are they afraid of being rejected like
what happened to them
what happened to them and to actually
write that scene even if it's not going
to be in the movie like what is the
scene
where they were rejected in some really
primal deep way
then
they are grounded in that character's
backstory and they don't have to do a
flashback
but everything they write is going to be
infused with that thing that happened to
them
and it's going to infuse the way that
they interact with the world and how
their fear gets triggered right
and so
a great character let's say let's say
they got rejected in their past
and they're going along in their life
and they want love but they don't have
it
and the call to adventure is
oh my god that person
that's my person
but they refuse the call because they're
too afraid of being rejected right again
so we're getting internal conflict
and then
maybe i can do it this time maybe i can
actually put myself out there so they
talk to their friends or they get some
guidance from somebody you know and like
in the meeting the mentor section of the
hero's journey
and they they realize like if i do if i
if i do this then maybe i'll i'll be
able to be with that person and so they
decide to go for it and they commit to
like
i'm gonna i'm gonna make that person
love me
you know and they set off on their quest
and now we're in act two and they go for
their goal and there's people who are
helping them like yeah yeah he really is
really into you let's do this you know
and someone people are trying to stop
stop her i'm just gonna say it's a she
at this point you know like
you're not his type
he likes this other girl like putting
that fear so that that fear is
externalized through a character that
can press on that character in the story
and but they really want that person so
bad and so they keep moving forward and
the middle of act two in the hero's
journey is called approach to the inmost
cave and the way to think about your
story in this section is that in the
cave is the treasure which is that
person that she wants
to fall in love with her
right and she really wants that person
really badly
but the cave is made up of her fear
because she wants him she's she's going
to go for him but as she's going for him
she gets more and more vulnerable
and so her emotions get triggered
and she's afraid and maybe you know a
lot of times in a romantic comedy or a
romance story you know the midpoint in
act 2 is a kiss or some kind of intimate
connection
and that triggers let's just say for our
character that we just made up right now
that triggers her fear like oh my god
i'm
so she pushes away again to protect
herself and the other person's like wait
what's going on i thought we and she's
you know and then she she does something
even more sort of out of her fear
and now she's at the end of act two
she's completely alone she's blown it
and she's failed and that person is with
someone else
and she's never ever gonna have that
person
love her
okay
but then
maybe the mentor comes in or maybe she
discovers something
that allows her to believe she has a
chance one more chance and so she
decides
i'm going to try to get him one more
time and that launches her into act
three and then there's that race you
know or she's trying to get to the
person whatever
and in that scene
she has to face
her fear like like you know the classic
cliche version of this is like she's
running to the airport oh my god he's
leaving on a play she gets there and
there goes the plane
he's gone
right so that s that death of her dream
at the end of act two where she failed
is reenacted once more and it's like oh
my god she's not going to get what she
wants
but then she turns and there he is he
didn't get on the plane or
he goes on the plane and he leaves
and in a scene that happens after that
they meet again by accident or something
and she tells him
how she feels and she opens herself up
and she's completely vulnerable which is
her growth and her transformation and
because she's grown and because she's
revealed
her true feelings
he's like hell yeah i'll be with you and
she gets what she wants
so the hero's journey by creating this
idea of the fear in in the character and
actually grounding it in a real thing
that's something you can play with in
the story to create emotional growth for
the main character
and another way that i like to think
about um creating emotional structure
for the for the character in the story
is that you know
how are they going to change
and um this may be a richard walter
thing again i don't know if i'm pulling
this from richard i probably am but he i
think in his book he talks about
this idea of um like a bow and arrow
and if you're let's just say you know at
the end of this movie that you're
writing that she's gonna stand before
him
and say how much she loves him and be
really vulnerable
so that's the that's where the arrow
lands right so in creating the arc the
emotional arc you want to pull that that
arrow back as far away from that as you
can
so that
there it looks like there's no way she
can ever be vulnerable with anybody okay
so that you're you're creating these
this polarity in the story of how who
she is at the beginning what her belief
system is about herself and the world
and then how it changes at the end and
then you're kind of building the
emotional journey between those two
poles so that's another way to think
about creating emotional structure
you know as you were speaking i it was
taking me back to 16 candles oh my god
so i mean i i realize i'm going back a
few years but i'm so i'm thinking of the
molly ringwald character yes and she's
feeling left out because her sister's
wedding right yeah and and everybody's
busy yes and then
she has the crush on jake jake right
yeah you all remember jake and he's got
like sort of the cheerleader girlfriend
and in her mind
he's totally unattainable but he was
perfect right and so she's at the dance
and then she gets sort of this
unwanted attention but it's part mentor
right the the one and forgive me it was
anthony michael hall yes okay yeah and
and he was awesome in the film and he's
kind of a mentor but he's also trying to
pick her up yeah yeah and and so
you know and then yeah we don't want to
spoil it even though the movie is 30
plus years okay all right it's it's been
it's been a little yeah but so then
there's the moment where there he is yes
and yeah it's the awkward and i forget
he's got his car he probably has like
this or whatever yeah yeah and so and
then they have the weird conversation
and
you know yeah so i'm thinking of i'm
thinking of that that's exactly how yeah
the all is lost right at the end of act
two we have it where you know the the
person is with someone else and then the
character has to kind of relive it in
the climax again
right
um and um that character of jake it's so
interesting because i i watched that
movie a few months ago his character is
so problematic
oh is he oh yeah i mean it's but it's
fascinating to watch it from 2021
back and and going oh yeah we thought
that was okay or whatever you know a lot
of the stuff that happens in that movie
but that's exactly what i'm talking
about that emotional structure of like
there he is
you know and um
yeah and sometimes the way that that
emotional growth happens in the climax
is also
you know like the the harrow is sort of
in the climax it looks like they're
they're they're not going to get what
they want again you know that person's
gone or whatever
but because of what they've learned on
the journey they do something
emotionally they never could have done
at the beginning of the movie and
because they do it in that moment
they actually get what they want and
they might not get it in the want in the
way that they wanted or thought they
would get it back then but it's it could
be in a new way that is actually even
better than the way they thought they
were going to get it
you